-Congrats, by the way,
on the new Marvel chapter
in your life.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, thank you.
Mysterio.
-They know.
Dude, it was a big deal
when the trailer came out.
You're gonna be Mysterio
in the new "Spider-Man."
-Yes.
-And I was psyched about that.
And I saw that Ryan Reynolds,
our pal, posted a --
I'm gonna cross this out
'cause there was a couple
dirty words.
You can't see it.
-Oh, wow.
-Ryan Reynolds posted a photo
of you and Hugh Jackman
at a holiday party.
-That's Photoshopped.
We weren't actually together.
[ Laughter ]
-And it said, "These dudes
said it was a sweater party."
So, you --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. I think it's the greatest
photo -- greatest reaction.
I just loved that.
And I thought it was great.
So then,
you finally joined Instagram.
-Yeah.
-You, what -- I mean --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're the last holdout!
-Thank you!
I mean --
-You're the last holdout, dude.
We've been waiting for you.
-The last person
to join Instagram.
-Yes, Instagram's
been waiting for you.
-Yeah, I came to the conclusion
that nobody cares
about anything anymore,
so I should join Instagram.
[ Laughter ]
-No, people -- They care.
-Oh, they do?
-Yeah.
That's why they join Instagram.
-Oh, yeah, no.
-They care about everybody.
-I'm not even sure
if I'm on Instagram.
-You're definitely on.
-I am?
-I've seen you on Instagram.
-No, I'm on Instagram.
-Yeah, you are.
-I'm on Instagram.
-Well, you took that photo --
That was that photo.
And then, you took --
You Photoshopped that photo.
And then, you,
Deadpool, you're on Wolverine --
Is that bubble boy?
-Yes, that is bubble --
[ Laughter ]
And Spider-Man, too,
in the corner.
-Yeah, that's Spidey
over there in the corner.
-That's Spider-Man
in the corner.
That's actually
a guy named Bosslogic.
He did that actually.
-Oh, is that
who did that for you?
-Yeah, we should give
a shout-out to that guy,
'cause I have
no artistic skill whatsoever.
There'd be no possibility
that I could pull that off.
-Bosslogic?
-Bosslogic, yeah.
-"Baas" or "Boss"?
-I don't know, man.
-I mean, do you know somebody
named Bosslogic?
-That's the guy
who did that picture --
Bosslogic.
"Ba-sla-jik."
-"Ba-sla-jik"?
-"Ba-sla-jik."
-His name is "Bas-laji."
-"Bas-laji."
-Oh, Bosslogic.
-It's Bosslogic.
-Oh, my gosh.
Yeah, no, of course.
-He's amazing.
-Nikolai Baslajic, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He's a CIA agent.
He's wanted in 30 countries.
Yes!
-Baslajica?
-Yes, in Baslajica.
Baslajica -- that's where
he's from, of course.
But, dude,
here's you as Mysterio.
Look at this.
You came on the screen,
people went "Whoa!"
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, and how's --
See what I'm saying, dude?
-Who knew --
Who knew that --
The thing is, is like,
those are the actual
green lasers
that I shoot out of my hands.
-Yes, I've known that for years.
-That's what I can do,
and that's why they hired me.
-And finally, you can put that
to good use in a film.
-Yeah, finally!
Finally!
-I mean, you play tricks
when you're in movie theaters
and stuff.
-When I was a kid,
my dad's like,
"What are we gonna do
with this kid."
-Laser hands!
Oh, my gosh.
And now, here you are
in a big-time movie.
-Yeah!
It paid off, man.
-How's Tom Holland?
-He's great, dude.
-Dude, he's great?
-He's awesome.
-Yeah, he's good.
-He's the nicest guy.
In the world.
-He is.
-I'm super into him
as Spider-Man.
-Yeah.
But I think it's more fun
what you're doing on Instagram.
You're kind of
trolling him a little bit.
-My God.
This whole Instagram thing...
You're really into it.
-Dude, I'm totally --
-You are obsessed
with my Instagram.
-Oh, yes, your Instagram.
-[ Laughing ]
Yeah, follow Jake on Instagram,
@jakegyllenhaal.
-That's my name.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm surprised you got that name
'cause you weren't
on Instagram so long.
Somebody else probably took it.
-I think someone
snatched it up pretty early.
-Did you have to buy it
from a stranger?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-That said
that they were Jake Gyllenhaal?
-No.
Someone got it for me.
[ Laughter ]
-Just tell me.
-I got friends.
-Was it Baslajic?
-Baslajic.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know about that guy.
That guy can do anything.
You want it done,
call Baslajic.
-Bosslogic is freaking out
right now.
-He will take care of it, man.
He will take care
of all of it.
-I had it.
Someone had it.
I don't know how he had it,
but we had it.
-Well, you have it now.
It's @jakegyllenhaal.
And you posted this funny thing,
I thought, of Tom Holland.
I think he was
just doing an interview.
You took all the vocals --
all the audio
out of his interview,
added this weird music.
Just watch.
♪♪
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-He's just...amazing.
[ Laughter ]
-He's just dreamy.
-He just is.